I am a loyal ingress of the European
Parliament loyal linguist often confused
with translators were not translators
we're responsible as the name of our
Directorate implies for the quality of
legislation so we try and ensure that
any legislation that is adopted by the
EU is legally coherent factually correct
but also linguistically the coherent or
language versions are equally authentic
so we have to ensure that they all say
exactly the same thing as loyal ingress
our job is to ensure the highest
possible quality of legislative texts in
the European Union that means that we
follow all the legislative procedures
from the very beginning to the very end
that means from the time that the
Commission proposal arrives at the
European Parliament until the
publication in the Official Journal we
take part in all the meetings within the
committees at linear level and the
inter-institutional negotiations and we
give drafting advice to the political
actors I studied law and being half
English and half Italian I studied
English law and Italian law I studied
law in Germany Sweden and England and
then I completed my practical legal
training in Germany I'm qualified as a
German lawyer
you're constantly involved with the most
up-to-date legislation even before it
comes out on the news you've been
involved in to a certain extent the
negotiations for it and yes an example
was just recently working on the
accession treaty for Croatia and my
colleague that was responsible for it
then went to the the signing ceremony
met all the heads of state so it is
something quite prestigious about it I'm
working currently on the
intergovernmental treaty and so that's
yet another interesting aspect in my job
I work with law I work with politics and
I work with language and these are three
fields I've always been passionate about
so that's something I really enjoy as
well the languages I use essentially or
English because I'm an English team
that's the language they use essentially
in negotiations or otherwise French the
legal service is still very much in
viewed with the French culture so we do
use French very often as well at my
current job I mainly use English because
that's the language in which laws are
negotiated these days I used German
because I verify the German texts I
sometimes use French because but
sometimes used as well and I also
understand Swedish and Spanish and I
have basics and Dutch but that I are
only used for comparison sometimes our
department assists us very much it
organizes a lot of training for
newcomers but also for more experienced
colleagues and I've been involved in
preparing some of those trainings and so
it's a great experience not only to
receive training but to also give
training so there's a lot of
opportunities here
I've always wanted to work in a
multicultural and multilingual
environment where I meet people from
different cultures and with different
backgrounds and I have that so I enjoy
that tremendously I love it I wouldn't
be able to adapt to anything less than
that so absolutely great
perhaps I'm assisted by by my grounds
but absolutely you know being in touch
with different cultures different
nationalities learning about different
traditions is a very enriching
experience